ils partagent leur vie et ont aussi un
gros problème en commun diane et richard
sont des patients orphelins leur médecin
de famille est partie à la retraite de
jean deux ans qu'on est contre on
cherche puis l'on utilise que oui quand
la caméra quand même avoir fait que
faute de médecins ils sont pris en
charge par une infirmière la dernière
fois qu'on s'est vu des changements la
santé vie rené gagnon est l'une des
trois infirmières de la clinique d'accès
intégré de magog donc j'ai le droit de
vous prescrire la sanguins tels que vous
le désirez et aussi la de vous
rencontrer pour faire l'est le gil dans
le but de faire le dépistage pour le
cancer de l'utérus elle prescrivent des
examens de dépistage est fondée suivi de
maladies chroniques et le diabète et à
la haute pression et le taux de
cholestérol plus élevé une autonomie
délégués par les médecins de la région
c'est la beauté de la chose elles sont
autonomes alors autonome et elles n'ont
pas besoin de d'approbation médical pour
poser ce geste là
richard et diane sont satisfaits moi je
trouve un bon compromis puis même en
fait en ce moment j'ai pas besoin de
maîtrise heureusement pour lui parce que
l'estrie a de moins en moins de médecins
de famille ça fait
beaucoup plus de départs à la retraite
et deux médecins qui quittent la
première ligne aussi que d'arrivées
nouveaux médecins donc à chaque année il
ya un écart qui se creuse ce qui fait
que la proportion d'estriens qui ont un
médecin de famille a baissé en 2010 8
86% de la population étaient inscrites
auprès d'un médecin s'investit à 81 2%
l'an dernier déléguer des
responsabilités aux infirmières devient
carrément incontournable avec une
pénurie de médecins de famille au québec
on ne peut plus assurer seul l'entièreté
des besoins de la population
ces besoins là doivent être répartis sur
d'autres professionnels la prise en
charge pour moi ne doit plus maintenant
la question d'un médecin mais elle doit
être la question de plusieurs personnes
en estrie médecins et infirmières
travaillent déjà main dans la main
quelques indices vérifier si la personne
a des symptômes de thyroïde mais les
médecins garde un rôle conseil si la
situation devient encore plus complexe
alors l'oeil un médecin répondant qui
peut répondre à la situation seuls les
cas plus complexes sont référés à un
médecin dans cette clinique quand qu'ils
viennent chez nous c'est vraiment parce
que ben il y avait vraiment besoin de
voir un médecin qui on n'a pas trouvé
d'autres professionnels qu'ils pouvaient
répondre à son besoin et environ 30% des
patients vus ici par la docteur caroline
langlet n'ont pas de médecin de famille
ayew café c'est le cas de robert
turcotte tout juste arrivé de toronto où
il n'avait pas non plus de médecins de
famille
gp avec ce système c'est moins
dérangeant de ne pas être inscrit auprès
d'un médecin est dit il
ce nouveau québécois est enchantée par
l'efficacité du système implanté en
estrie
c'est bien mieux qu'à toronto dit
monsieur scott parce que l'accès à des
soins est un problème pancanadien avec
le vieillissement rapide de la
population
la solution ne peut plus passer
uniquement par les médecins ici david
gêne-t-il et radio canada
magog
oui